I'm going go [ __ ] go why is this not
going oh my god hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to the walking
dead saints and sinners now this is a VR
game that is supposedly very realistic
in terms of the oh I don't know I could
do that that's helpful but this game is
supposed to be very imagine the
sensation of a zombie grabbing you by
the throat and trying to bite into your
soft meaty supple body that's what this
game is trying to replicate that feeling
ok so without further ado let's get into
this I'm ready I'm ready
just another survivor just another
survivor let's do this let's do this
let's do this let's do didn't call me
the tourist people call me the tourist
I'm ready I'm ready
just another survivor people call me the
tourist Oh skin tone whoa let's see what
looks like me I mean I can't tell if
this is pasty or more tan than this one
this one seems kind of great I'm gonna
go with this one this one seems good
yeah ooh immersive keep an eye on your
watch and listen for the warning beeps
be ready to rush back to the skiff when
you hear the bells when I hear the bell
I'm sorry what are the bells I'm really
a hundred percent fully know what the
bells are oh you can you guys even see
that probably not oh my god
Oh reach down your left hip and grab the
small weapon in the holster huh what the
[ __ ] hello what the [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] oh
this is gonna be problematic if people
in the game can hear me return the
weapon to the holster and let go but
before I do that oh wait no hang on huh
wait wait wait wait stop
you hold hold the horses they're
controls okay I want this to be hold
okay okay this way because if I grab it
and let's go yeah that's better
oh this is gonna be cool but I think I'm
also hitting my loss so I gotta make
sure I keep up a nice chin I gotta go
down like this make sure I don't bump
into me
oh I thought I was gonna [ __ ] it okay
ooh there's a timer Oh anybody in the
dark just want a piece of me boning Bank
oh no I can't Boom Bang II I love that I
love this I love the feel of this this
is a good feel
oh this is nice right shoulder and grab
the large weapon oh mama
hole mom is at the center of mass oh
yeah buddy you know it is oh mama
oh wow grab and pull out the backpack
what the hell that's so cool oh that's
so cool oh this is so cool this is so
rad Oh take food from your backpack and
hold it in your mouth to eat and restore
stamina oh don't oh my goodness I'll
just take nutrias stew that's some good
stuff
take bandages from your backpack ooh
wrap them around yes I will oh my god
I'm actually wrapping them what oh my
god I know this isn't a big deal to you
guys but this is a really big deal to me
this is cool this is legitimately cool I
don't know how it's gonna go later on
but I like what it is right now reach
over your right side and grab and pull
out your journal right side you mean my
my pocket doing this is just rad oh how
many things do I have I'm never gonna
remember all this Oh what was that
oh oh oh I don't like that oh I don't
like that it'll auto returned to my
chest
that's good be bad if I drop that whole
turn journal oh [ __ ] oh hi what are the
water those what are those
let's go yeah strutting on up
give me this Pierce the walkers brain to
kill them well they're not exactly
walking jack the mo a Crouch run push oh
oh my god they're just armless oh my god
they are can i flippy-floppy this why do
I always have to do it stabby style
alright so I need to stab you in the
brain right let me get a look at you
first
oh that's sad ooh that is sad you are
actually just an armless Walker ah good
sorry need to Oh lost a little tracking
there but that's okay
oh you know what actually I'm gonna I'm
gonna get rid of the ghosts okay I need
that oh god oh god oh god get rid of the
ghosts okay hi how you doing uh could I
just
oh oh nice why is this glowing red is it
because of the soul of the Damned that I
just stabbed is embedded now inside of
it and it is forever cursed to
perpetuate the cycle of killing
endlessly oh tutorial show oh it's it's
got durability or something
yeah right through the eyeball oh oh it
broke no it broke did you see that it
broke friend-friend it broke
friend-friend it broke her friend friend
I can't grab on with both hands what's
even the point
friend there you go friend you are
supposed to be back in there I didn't
not been oh oh I can grab things I think
I'm trying to grab no I swear this is
not what I'm going for
hey well I'm up now alright pull you the
rest of the way in get you back in your
hole oh my god okay I'm gonna
OOP
I liked hello oh look I'm terrible sorry
about this get off of my ax thank you I
know I really put my back into that one
but I don't think that actually did like
did that much for me okay anyway oh oh
oh there she goes
proceed to the next area you got it
Buster Brown you got it bibbidi bobbidi
this is old a problem that's a problem
over there alright let's go there just
moseying my way downtown excuse me
just need to grab myself here shake off
the walkers when they grab you listen no
touch listen no touch no touch hey hey
stop it hey hey no no no no no get back
you stay away stay away I don't know
what's going on with your feet there but
I can't seem to move okay what happens
if I just punch you wake up where do I
got my flashlight on you go
you can grab walkers and shove them away
you can shove offers back holding too
into weapons weapons and items have
durability can break some guns
durability or low they can jam recaulk
the gun to unjam [ __ ] it you say I want
to [ __ ] don't move Oh mm-hmm I have no
ammo Oh box Oh store it in your ammo
pouch I have on the limited ammo put
that bear move on hi what you doing over
there what you got a gun oh just a
little lost dude in the middle of a
zombie apocalypse oh god I don't trust
you the answer would be yes hey don't
shove me away don't shove me don't show
that you've seen all there is to see
would you like to exit the combat
tutorial sure would shrimpy sure what
will the B button and use the right
stick Oh B wait this is a bottle Oh on
the other one yes sure about that
on second have at it then how about it I
will
what's in here wait a minute what isn't
here wait oh wait no for Orleans Parish
Bayou when we could go down Taurus in
the flames me Oh story about you been
buzzing all over in a bayou aha what is
the reason older but if the city's where
you're headed well I suspect your story
is just beginning
well you'd be right about that my story
is just beginning mostly just because I
don't know what my story is and also I
don't know why you know who's the
friendly warning nor no soul to another
the dead
maybe the only thing to be fearing and
the Big Easy
oh wow oh
I would help but apparently I can't did
that stray bullet just hit me the tower
on one side oh you're not here Oh ideas
oh hi something tells me I don't want to
see this
oh yeah I saw it well oh those were
clean renegades our home beyond that
making everyone's skin crawl with their
Horror Show tactics aha great and the
powder keg that's gonna make the whole
city blow the reserve I can tell by the
spot it jumped up in your eyes that
you've heard the legend disaster relief
supplies
Oh in the flood to end all floods hit
in an old military bunker all never
distributed to the people because the
government didn't know its ass from a
hole in the ground make sense before
they could figure it out the day had
started walking huh
all those meds military
and ambled to boot seems like a narrow
pass time one touch it didn't get you
out and it's my job to go get it yes it
was close to another know me that's
right look at oh and you but this broken
body has seen better days
uh-huh and I need to get after it real
quick before the fools get wise uh-huh
so if you find yourself each and to step
out of the Bayou and help out an old man
ah well you can find me in the cemetery
where I'm holed up
aha the cemetery 50/50 split in your
future uh-uh I ain't greedy I ain't no
fool okay oh I got em individuals a real
nice tourist you just might be what this
needs
but then again maybe you're the type to
pull the whole godforsaken place under
maybe I am mayhaps I be that mayhaps I
am listen this is where I say no I'll
take that thank you or no
no-oh-oh I'm under the water so I'm dead
the Bayou seemed to be flooded up with
those dudes so I'm just assuming that
I'm dead
go for a dip you go rip get in the drink
you're gonna sink fall in the lake life
gonna flake get in the water it's gonna
be a slaughter
hello improve your aim by gripping guns
with both hands always remember to use
the iron sights you don't always need to
sometimes you gotta like feel where the
bullets gonna go people didn't know the
Walking Dead universe and star wars are
it's one in the same day one late
evening hello oh well well well if it
isn't that cemetery I heard so much
about okay
all right into the haunted cemetery I go
that Shh whoo old man named Henry lives
in this graveyard told me to meet him
here if I help him find the reserve
he'll split the supplies with me find
the old man's hideout okay you think he
would have given me more directions than
just in oh yeah you know I didn't
actually need to push that did it with
my mind I am a Jedi after all like I
said the force very big in this part of
town
Louisiana actually where the Jedi
Council was founded how many people know
this but I know this that is a dead body
or a dead body that might be alive also
known as a live body do I have a gun I
sure don't I got my finger guns crouched
oh you have a weapon you're crouched
makes you slower quieter and harder to
see indeed it does indeed it does my
friend indeed it does you might have
what the hell Oh
I don't know what happened oh I can
flippy flopper you like you ever seen
tricks like this before have you
good boy I hit my microphone but that's
okay how about one of these right up
your nose
who's on your I apparently creepy-crawly
some over there are you an egg timer
okay oh so it can probably attract
attention or something that's useful
you're right there I I do have a knife
in my pocket
okay that's lefty Lou I got screwdriver
on the right egg timers special for some
reason whatever all right I'm taking
this real slow because I'm still getting
used to everything just gonna ah there
we go just want to make sure I'm up well
these are out of place oh oh you're
gonna get it now
yeah the first one didn't take too well
but that one did okay
piercing the skull requires a broad
range of motion it does not require
extremely fast movement I disagree all
right a patrol had a scrape with a
couple of reclaimed in Old Town
yesterday sirens got messed up pretty
bad uh-huh but the savages paid the
price uh-huh
one of the corpses had this drawing
uh-huh look familiar
uh-huh doesn't bode well that little
[ __ ] in her trailer mother working with
the reclaim to locate the reserve time
is not on our side no more [ __ ]
around hey watch your language so keep
this between us for now okay cautious
but aggressive we stir the herd at 1700
keep on the hunt till the last minute
the tower will always stand Georgia Oh
Georgia okay you talking about the state
or your name well you couldn't see
that's probably why you couldn't see him
sneaking up on you well this is
downright fascinating huh I'm not seeing
much else uh and I don't know what the
big Tower thing is about but this is a
hole as fast
it really is oh I could go that way I
bet that door squeaky final things about
doors that ones squeaky let's turn this
off he's going screwdrive mode it's time
to getting screwed oh you want some soup
oh you want some soup you want some soup
ah you want some soup
okay all right soup delivery right here
oh sorry
looks like that soup was too spicy for
ya oh that's prawn biting position and
one more for good man oh maybe I'll save
it all right so apparently if you stand
right in front of them they can see you
I thought their vision was based on
movement but turns out I'm an idiot
all right cool let's go oh yeah this is
this is super fun like I really cannot
deny this is super fun hello
what are you a reindeer what's going on
with your head oh you have a mask
can I have a mask can I have that
apparently not who's chanting who's
doing the chanting yun byung-se's real
nice yeah my friend no Henry we're not
friends
relax it's me what happened to you what
a veneer
I kept my mouth shut he didn't get [ __ ]
out already the bus oh my god okay Ari
well I mean you're not dead yes oh haha
read now we can be friends who is she
who are you talking about who are you
talking about
well as far as last words ago that was
pretty mysterious oh you're not dead
okay I thought oh now are you not now
you're oh oh right the zombie thing I
kind of forgot about that whole ordeal
here this would be a mercy then let me
just gonna swing around the back of you
here so you can't really give me listen
Ari we weren't friends but you know we
had some good times you and I sure so
long waterfall I'll leave that there you
know what you you you weren't no yeah
you oh no wait no this is ceremonial you
earned that nope
come on honey just take the dim I'm
trying to be look we're not friends but
listen I was trying to do your solid
there you'd have look I don't know I
guess leaving murder weapon but you
would have already been dead hello time
to make an example of the old man uh-huh
we have let his transgressions slide for
too long okay track him down carve them
up hobble him a bit but let him live JB
would like to have a chat with him he
thinks he might be connected to the
voice popping up on the airwaves from
time to time and you know how JB feels
about competition all ears should be
tuning in to the reclaimed okay timber
all right um well I guess people love
shouting your name what's the dealio
with this whole reserve seems awfully
mysterious and also non-existent listen
I I would love to stick around on Ari
but uh old and stone gathers no moss uh
I think that's an appropriate slogan
here also awfully convenient that both
of these groups decided to attack you at
once so you know not bad for you anyway
all right let's see what the deal is
with over there ah so here's your
problem at the base honoré it wasn't
exactly fortified doesn't seem to be
anything in the way of fortifications
here
Oh graveyard strut Ella bus is it the
old man's hideout rusted-out bus better
look around trying to piece together
what he had on the reserve wouldn't hurt
to get some [ __ ] out - yeah it seems
like a safe place to sleep this is
definitely secure what is this arrows
don't mind if I does take that thank you
owe me what's yours is mine and what's
mine is no longer yours cuz you're dead
food restores max stamina but rotten
food lowers max health medicine restores
max health bandages restore health max
stamina will decrease as you exert
yourself yeah I know how the human body
works what is this Oh survival station
oh I need to crap this so I can make
these ah yah
Wow sois oh let sois oh whoa
yes please so this is the gun station
all right so I need two metal bolts nuts
and bolts to be able to get the gun then
I can make a revolver hell yeah and also
I can make Oh double barrel shotgun yes
please was that rifle haha both action
love it for times when accuracy matters
which is never hints of Krieger station
and unlock the next recipes craft new
gear and items with white recipes blue
recipes are permanent upgrades unlocked
Green recipes by discovering special
recipes that are hidden in the world
neato burrito this is rad I'm totally
down for this this is not what I was
expecting when this game was presented
in front of me but I liked it
okay hungry hello
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding what is this oh
it's a radio no there's no power to the
bus
he's like a battery here or something
hello there needs to be a battery right
here whoa whoa look at the notes to read
them and gain the clues well I gotta
grab the knife first what do we have
here Shaboom
the reserve it's out there it exists
this Jung I found proves it still so
much work to be done
waterfowl and frequencies 61 has to be
connected to the reserve somehow command
and control listen that's the next step
if I can get this blasted radio over
there wonder if someone is still inside
as soon as my ankle feels steady gonna
take this gift to that mansion in the
Garden District when Niles and I
recorded the tipsy blue record the blue
palace it's my best shot at finding a
microphone for the radio towers covered
with the bus battery just got connected
antenna 2 got encryption covered can't
afford and the eavesdroppers
never slept in three days these creaky
bones
Rockman with excitement could sure use
the florists help though he'll how to
even be willing to split four to sixty
if they make all is easier hope they
show up before it's too late
no I mean it's only been a week you kind
of really aged much in a week this is
the last time we met but you know this
like a radio or something he's going ah
ok mmm
and then 10 I meant I know the
difference between a radio and an
antenna oh I'm an American soldier I'm a
warrior a member of a team I serve the
people the United States and like the
live the Army Values oh uh okay so go
ahead do I need to repeat that to
someone I'm gonna slam this soon here
bonk okay whatever
I don't think I can do that yet because
you said something about there not being
a microphone in there I think what this
means is I just got to go to sleep seems
like there's a piece of a gun there for
craftable later but nothing for me now
so why not a little nib Oh slug down a
sweet delectable taste of whatever the
hell you old man had well it looks like
I'm on a mission now the dead have grown
in number well that doesn't make any
sense because I killed honoree and he
was probably the only one that died oh
hey la voz hey la booze I didn't even
like close a door or anything on this
thing ah good morning everybody good
morning my friends Kelly how you doing
bud hey how you doing
you seem like you're gonna be a
permanent member of the team very
helpful so what is what is this all
about your breasts are clean your brush
here junk Oh candlestick I don't need a
candlestick this is cool though because
now I can recycle stuff oh I can
probably recycle this this might just be
broken I am NOT on even care
pistol' frames that's how I got it
pistol frames neato burrito if you hear
the bells run I don't know uh oh is that
the person that I'm going for nice rats
those look tasty delicious this is where
the game actually starts you know what I
mean this is where the real [ __ ] starts
to go I just want to see what's in this
area real quick before I go running off
to anywhere else because there might be
some goodies hello okay I just wanted to
feel that for a second
Oh what is this yeah a box of stuff some
handy pieces oh well that's helpful how
do I open it sure would I open it do I
just gotta go put it in the recycling oh
I guess oh my god I have a box of stuff
I got a box of stuff nobody can stop me
nothing else I need here no other
goodies this is have any ammo in it
yes Oh does that bullet in it nevermind
we're good okay select location on the
map to travel the shallows oh we're off
okay we're good we're going okay all
right so this is like the first time
that I'm on my vow that is dead bodies
Oh
prepare the radio search the blue
mansion for a microphone it sounds easy
enough
I'm guessing that there are zombies here
so I'm not gonna go in to willy-nilly
only moderately willy-nilly oh who the
hell do you think you are oh yeah that's
what people say when they want to trap
me I've seen some what episodes of The
Walking Dead I've begun they're not try
nothing hello
what has husband he's turn ya begged me
not to let it happen but I just couldn't
pull the trigger
oh he was all I had left but I failed
him mmm I'm so ashamed
would you be willing to help me out I
just can't bring myself to do it I need
someone else in this nightmare
yeah I wouldn't arrest I'll put them to
rest thank you so kind hey take this key
okay
second floor of the blue mansion just up
the street
oh well handy that's exactly where I was
heading it looks like you've got the
along and sync with the chiming bells
that rile up the walkers everyday smart
smart want to be caught out in an open
when this place is overrun by the day no
way nohow
and um one last request yes
Ruben's wedding band if you could
retrieve it it would mean so much to me
you know what okay all right okay it
sounds like the ring couldn't have been
much useful scrap anyway so I guess it's
not really a it's not really a big deal
if I give it to you so yeah that sounds
that's the I guess it's fair yeah that's
that seems fair ah dah sorry don't mind
me I'm a bit of a cave woman over here
fire wis crap you've scrapped me scrap
ki good alright see you around I'll take
care of it don't worry about a thing
okay is that whoa that's heavy listen
here I don't think I can put this in my
backpack good eye ah no way no how you
kill carry it I got it okay yeah yeah
I'm not [ __ ] the gas tank I'm just
it looks like I'm [ __ ] it okay hey
bud no you didn't see me what do you
thinking what are you thinking about
what you thinking about it thinking
about nothing no no no no no you lost me
where'd I go weird
Oh No Oh No
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] yeah there we go okay um did not
go as I intended it to go yeah this is
accomplished left shadow and the night
nothing gets away from me hello now is
not the time to be safe now is the time
to commit to a community to be part of
something our vision for the future is
rooted in hope it ensures a future for
human ability despair there is no point
in clinging to it
do not commit to isolation dedicate
yourself to a grander purpose and you
will not be alone all those in us to
guide you and we will put our trust in
you within our walls you will be safe
I repeat it within our walls your maybe
noir is its later maybe noir is a liar
and a thief she will say I'm do anything
to further her own selfish agenda
do not be fooled she will not help she
will go up to you I considered her
family treated her as if she were my own
flesh and blood yet she did not hesitate
to betray me she tried to turn my
dearest and most loyal friends against
me how her treachery knows no bounds she
is desperate and will do the same to you
do not be fooled
maybe noir is a menace
she should be shunned if you assist her
in any way you will leave us no choice
but to consider you an enemy of the
tower we do not wish they do not force
our hand the tower will always stand
okay that's the same one as that one
mama called me mama what's going on here
what's the deal use a grip to grab oh is
this the broom is this big blue this
looks like big blue we have going on
here
I I just I'm gonna I'm just gonna commit
that sometimes you're just gonna seem
what was that what did I just see over
there Oh whoo I don't like that what's
going on what's going on over there
what's going on what's over there what
happened who's here I thought I heard
something over here oh I did it's a rat
okay I'm assuming the rats aren't that
bad for me
Oh God they can hear me Oh oh it's this
side door wasn't even the front door
who's this pack of smokes that's not
helpful
who cares bad for my health ain't gonna
do that another jumpy any OOP is that a
juice box or something Cola orange blitz
why is it max health low some energy
drink bullcrap make me go faster or some
whatever oh god the craves I just
noticed that oh my god that's sad that's
depressing there's a way out there why
is there like a ritual entrance here Oh
what is this oh I don't like it oh I
really don't like it holy crap I don't
like it Oh
wowsie wowsie okay so why does this
exist it doesn't even seem to limit it
lead into the house at all oh yes it
does never mind
it is something there okay
I'm gonna poke my head up did that go in
my pocket
no did not my knife I just had my knife
where'd my knife go that's not my knife
that was that's a knife I somehow just
lost my knife I thought it was in my
head okay whatever knife find whoop
ooh so we got some kind of a puzzle but
the safe there keep grabbing the wrong
things okay that's good to know
perfect just okay cool that just goes in
my backpack I don't have to pull it out
every time which is good to know it's
bound to be plenty of dudes in there
just gonna go ahead and do this cool boy
this is actually kind of stressful oh
why
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine
cuz I'm gonna close this door and you're
never gonna know
looks like they lost me okay that's good
all right well that was a little spooky
Oh Oh God okay oh my god yeah how strong
are you not that strong Oh oh my god the
door the hell oh I'm talking duh so I
need to be quiet when I go through this
which is an interesting conundrum hello
that that a dirty bandage yep it's a
dirty bandage lots of goodies here
that's a rip box of razors it's just a
box of razors weird I'm just some psycho
talking to himself
I can really hear myself that going in
here how well can the zombies hear me
that's an interesting idea I like that
so I actually have to be careful when
I'm delivering soup this is spooky this
is legitimately spooky like it's not
like spooky like a full-on horror game
but it's it's spooky just because of the
implications of all of this the idea
that my voice travels the the the
concept of sneaking around spoon wonder
if all these have Stephanie they do well
[ __ ] do all of these open really oh my
god they do what do you mean full what
are you talking about for turns out you
can't just load up on the junk
I'll box those are out goddamnit yeah
this is this is very useful to have the
booze let's get rid of like not that the
spoon kitchen knife is good empty cans
just for noise oh [ __ ] oh this is legit
stressful no joke actually stressful and
also like the concept that there's all
of these different cabinets to explore
what is that breath mint maximum health
- 15 mm why does it lose me health if
its food its gain me health right breath
mint a wafer-thin it's just a breath
mint
good god I'd be dead by now if I lost
health from breath mints okay I gotta
get moving okay whoever's in here is
gonna get stabbed
what is that microphone that's not a
microphone oh I don't like the way those
moving the shadows that's really weird
oh I hate that Oh what is that about
oh I don't like that this is spooky
oh god ammunition holy [ __ ] finally
found the good room it's getting late
though I don't know exactly what happens
when [ __ ] goes down the Bell starts to
ring but I imagine it can't be good and
I'm starting to run out of time here
there we go this is what I'm looking for
the bullets the bullets yes okay where's
this dude oh he's in here
oh [ __ ] why why why hey who my dearest
Korean I lied to you I am sorry I had to
spare you
I lost hope our children die by my hand
I had to set them free to protect them
from a fate worse than death I know you
will never be able to forgive me but
maybe one day you will understand me
that I had no choice they did not suffer
take comfort in that my love oh well
that's really dark well I don't have the
most time in the world to worry about it
because it's getting real dark Suns
getting real low you know what I mean so
I'll let her know that well I guess I'll
have a choice to tell her the truth
I mean I'm gonna tell her the truth like
that would be horrible not to tell her
the truth but maybe it's maybe it's best
I don't know I don't know that breath
mint keep me minty fresh okay let's go
we gotta go we gotta get out of here
okay I don't remember that painting
being there again maybe I just didn't
look okay let's go
oh [ __ ] okay well you wanna you wanna
dance twinkle toes there you go you
danced nice dance yeah I why do you feel
he'll I don't know it's good some dirty
bandages done did that help or hurt it
didn't sound like a good sound so I'm
assuming it didn't help my head oh hey
hey bud listen getting pretty good at
that kind of curious as to what will
happen if I get caught out in the the
bells but uh maybe it's best not to find
out because it could be devastating to
my health what does that hurt me or
something yeah yeah yeah it's it's over
oh yeah the ring sorry it's in here
somewhere I got a lot of junk I picked
up here we go and Ewing there you go I
recovered the ring thank you this means
the world to me you're welcome
about that yeah ooh ooh yeah you know
I'm all about truth but maybe it's best
if you don't know who Jah God honesty is
sometimes the best policy but all you
have left is the memory so excuse my
cough would I want to know the truth
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey what did this fall off of my thing
well what the hell all right apparently
that fell off sorry my glasses it's I
fell off my face here I don't have a lot
of time for this so um ah [ __ ] you know
if if I was I would want to know there
is not a delicate way to put it your
husband killed your kids
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you why
would you say that to me after
everything I've been through what
[ __ ] proof do you have huh show me
proof from my journal okay save notes
can be free from my journal
select note well uh are you telling me I
didn't grab it I thought it went into
the journal you mean I didn't save it
Ruben's confessions here we go okay I
did get it here you go I found this note
I'm sorry I see please leave me be
take the [ __ ] code to the safe oh the
safe don't care 2:05 1 ah ok now you
know the truth hey listen it's been real
but I got to run because if I don't get
this before sundown I'm gonna be caught
out in the open I need to take some
medicine for that cough sounds real
rough baby good I feel so much better
well good thing I've got this
double-barrel shotgun cuz otherwise I
might being a little bit of trouble oh
ok ok this might get really real real
quick I I honestly have no idea yeah I
know you see me oh you see me too here
we go ok I don't have time to deal with
you 2:05 1 that's what the code is oh
wait
ok so if I take medicine then I can be
oh [ __ ] oh that's not good oh that's not
good oh that's not good come on give me
bit oh [ __ ]
oh not that one not that one
just one Oh God give me the goddamn
knife god damn it okay
that's not good um okay I got to get in
there and get this sick I got to get in
there and get out real fast I can make
this still I can still do this it's a
bottom floor here oh [ __ ] this is not
good we're my microphone oh god it's
locked
oh [ __ ] oh this is not good um I little
JIT 'mentally have no idea how bad
that's gonna be I would [ __ ] him Italy
god damn it just oh my god grab it and
go like seriously I have no idea what
that's gonna be like open cut okay where
was it I was back this way in one of
these rooms I gotta go I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go
205 one this is so not gonna be worth it
okay - no god damn it clear to 0-5 1
turn that open it open it open it
that's great this is great good I'm
probably gonna use all of these
did I just drop something no I didn't
okay this is great okay cool good all
right I gotta get out of here oh [ __ ]
here we go one down two down three down
no sorry not down okay got that one okay
so bad news they probably heard those
these all of this well god damn it oh my
god why am i crouching why now
get away oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god
I gotta go for this get away from how
you know okay oh god okay that's not
good
oh did I reload oh oh this is the
opposite of great this is the opposite
of great I'm out of stamina can't even
raise my gun right oh my god oh my god
I'm dead I'm [ __ ] dead huh I don't
know how to reload my revolver I haven't
even had a chance to really use it
respawn at this gift with all the your
loot will would be where you died wait
what if you die again before collecting
the loot the loo will be lost forever
oh god that's not good wait so I have
nothing I have one revolver okay that's
how you do it okay good god that was
actually stressful that was legitimately
stressful I I was I was not in a good
way there um okay I need some food I
don't have any sort of oh [ __ ] and there
I go okay here we go grab you one done
and shoot it I don't have a knife I
don't got nothing that's okay cuz I got
a gun and at the end of the day that's
all you need I don't have any food
either so that's the importance of food
that's the importance of medicine that's
the importance of staying fit that's the
importance of not running everywhere
that's the importance of a lot of things
who just spotted me
how did you spot me okay weird out the
sound it didn't exactly boom on that uh
when I thought I was gonna boom on [ __ ]
it's not the most wieldy of weapons but
it'll do
yeah cuz I don't have any food therefore
I'm really struggling but if I eat the
food I lose the health but I guess I
keep my stamina up which is more
important possibly thing okay I think I
had another this will do okay here we go
okay let's get back and let's let's get
some grub in me yep I know I know yes
got it
not that Oh dual wheel D baby maybe I
get why God okay I just gotta go for it
no that's not what I oh [ __ ] it's gone
oh [ __ ] oh god here we go oh god why ok
I'm going for it
[ __ ] it oh my god can't seem to get a
break ok there's the boat all I got to
do is get on the boat that's all I gotta
do and they couldn't possibly be that
close to me so I just got to get on the
boat that's all I gotta do okay
I'm gonna get on the boat I'm on the
boat I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm
going
go [ __ ] go why is this not going oh
my god go there go go get off of me yeah
I want to play hopscotch with it in my
hands that's what I want [ __ ] you huh
God so that was the walking dead saints
and sinners I'm gonna stop this one here
I'm gonna pause it and yeah you know
this is a fun game this is really fun
there's a lot of cool stuff happening
here there's a lot of cool concepts it's
gonna take some getting used to for me
but it's really fun and engaging it and
I think that that's that's like a unique
thing in VR right now it's starting to
get the point where games are evolving
how they allow you to interact with the
virtual world and doing it more and more
convincing ways I just make it fun and
engaging so that is saints and sinners
walking dead so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below if
you want to see more of this let me know
that as well leave a like if you enjoyed
it subscribe for more ring the bell if
you want to summon a horde of zombies
and as always I'll see you
[Music]